justo después de que resolver bien el
problema de las papas fritas del rey no
llega volando el ave mágica del rey la
cual se posa en su hombro y empieza a
susurrar en su oído y bueno seguramente
te sacas de onda y entonces le dices al
rey qué pasó qué fue lo que te dijo este
pájaro y el rey dice el pájaro real dice
que él piensa que tal vez existe otra
forma de resolver el problema y como tú
no estás acostumbrado a tomar consejos
de los pájaros y como seguramente te
pusiste un poco a la defensiva entonces
vas a decir bueno como el pájaro sabe
tanto vamos a ver como él resolvería el
problema y entonces el pájaro vuelva a
susurrar en el oído del rey y es cuando
el rey dice bueno voy a tener que
escribir yo la solución pues este pájaro
real no tiene manos así que el pájaro
sigue susurrando en el oído del rey
mientras que el rey traduce bueno
tomemos una de estas ecuaciones para
despejar una variable así que vamos a
tomar esta ecuación de azul para
despejar a una de las dos variables que
en esencia es escribir a una variable en
términos de la otra así que vamos a
intentarlo de aquí vamos a despejar a m
así que ojo vamos
despejar aemet de la ecuación de azul y
para esto lo primero que voy a hacer es
restar menos 400w de ambos lados de la
ecuación de tal manera que del lado
izquierdo me queda solamente snm
mientras que del lado derecho me queda
menos 400 w
más 1100 date cuenta que pasé de esta
ecuación a la otra restando 400w de
ambos lados de la ecuación de tal manera
que 400w menos 400w se cancelaron y
bueno ahora voy a dividir todo entre 100
todos los términos de 100 de tal manera
que tienen 300 pues me da solamente m
estos dos se van y del otro lado me
quedan menos 400 entre 100 lo cual es
menos cuatro menos 4 w y después me
queda 1100 entre 100 lo cual es 11 es
decir que m es igual a menos 4 w 11
bueno ahora que ya podemos escribir en
esta ecuación jaime en términos de w eso
es lo que dice el pájaro utilizando el
rey como traductor porque no sustituimos
el valor de m en la primera ecuación
pero en términos de w y así vamos a
obtener una ecuación con solamente una
incógnita así que vamos a poner 2
y después hay que poner un paréntesis
200 y pongo un paréntesis dice el pájaro
y en este paréntesis voy a poner el
valor de m pero el valor que acabamos de
construir con la segunda ecuación m es
igual a menos 4 w
11 por lo tanto voy a poner 200 que
multiplica a menos 4 w +11 menos 4 w
más 11 y después todo el resto más 300 w
es igual a 1200 más 300 w esto es igual
a 1200 y ojo
quiero hacer muy claro aquí está m que
tengo aquí es justa está en mí que acabó
de despejar en la segunda ecuación y que
acaba de sustituir en nuestra primera
ecuación así que te empiece a buscar la
cabeza porque empiezas a darte cuenta
que vas a obtener la misma respuesta que
obtuviste por suma y resta
quiero que pienses esto por un segundo
bueno pues el pájaro sigue susurrando en
el oído del rey y le dice que hay que
resolver esta ecuación con solamente una
incógnita y para eso lo primero que
vamos a hacer es distribuir este
doscientos por todo lo que está dentro
de este paréntesis y me queda 200 x
menos 4 w es menos 800 w y después 200
por 11 lo cual es 2200 ya todo esto hay
que agregarle más 300 w y esto es igual
a mil 200 mil 200 y bueno ahora vamos a
reducir todo lo que tiene que ver con w
esto y esto tiene que ver con w y por lo
tanto vamos a operarlo menos 800 w más
300 w
esto es lo mismo que menos 500 w ya esto
hay que sumarle 2200 y esto tiene que
ser igual a 1200 muy bien y ahora a
continuación lo que queremos es despejar
a w por lo tanto voy a restar menos 2200
de ambos lados de la ecuación para que
ya no quede solo lo que tiene que ver
con w del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
de tal manera que todos se van y
solamente me queda menos 500 w
esto del lado izquierdo mientras que el
lado derecho me queda
200 menos 2.200 lo cual es menos 1000 y
justo en este momento ya empieza todo
embonar porque si divido a ambos lados
entre menos 500 que me va a quedar del
lado izquierdo estos dos se van y
solamente me queda w mientras que del
lado derecho me queda 2 que es justo la
respuesta que obtuvimos en el vídeo
pasado utilizando el método de suma y
resta utilizando el método de
eliminación es la cantidad de bolsas de
papas fritas que come cada una de las
mujeres así que te sorprendes porque
parece que este método de sustitución
que nos acaba de decir el pájaro se
lleva bastante bien con nuestro método
de suma y resta o de eliminación que
vimos en el vídeo pasado para resolver
este problema de las papas fritas y
bueno si lo que quieres es saber cuántas
fuerzas de papas fritas se come cada uno
de los hombres puedes hacer lo mismo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado es decir
sustituir este valor que ya tenemos de w
en algunas de estas dos ecuaciones o en
su dado caso puedes hacerlo en esta
ecuación que tenemos aquí lo cual sería
mucho más fácil porque en esta ecuación
ya tenemos a m despejada intentado por
ti mismo para que veas que llegamos al
mismo resultado
creo que sería bastante bueno empezamos
a llevar bien con este pájaro